Well, hey there. Thank you for being
here and an especially warm welcome if
this is your first time with us.
Adventist or otherwise. Question of the
night, aka topic of the night.
What is the purpose of the ten
commandments in the life of the
Christian? An important topic. So, I'm
looking forward to the discussion. But
first, if you like what we're doing
here, I want to remind you that you can
support us by becoming a channel member.
Simply click that little join button
down below this video or visit the link
in the description box down below.
You'll gain access to our growing
library of membersonly content,
including membersonly live streams. The
next of which is tomorrow where we're
going to get uh get into some of the uh
behind the curtain sort of stuff, if you
will. I've never really done this in
live stream before, so should be
interesting. Um if that interests you,
we're going to be doing some historical
digging together. Um we're going to go
down the rabbit hole on a couple of
historical matters. If that interests
you, consider joining us. Like I said,
um you can click the link in the
description box down below if you don't
see the little join button down below
this video. It is because you are either
in a country where it's not supported or
you might be on a mobile device and you
might have to check on a desktop
computer. Thank you so much to all of
our members for their support.
Gentlemen, thank you so much for being
here. Matt, I will start with you. Let
people know who are you and then Mike,
you can do the same.
Cool. Uh my name is Matt Maria, live in
New York and I uh have been a 7th
Adventist since 2004.
Uh previously was really no association
to religion only in name uh namely
Catholic. Um so it's been quite some
time. Uh I did uh I did uh take a break
so to speak. Uh veered off a little bit
and for quite some time but then uh was
reclaimed uh by the Lord Jesus. So, uh,
now I'm, you know, I'm a local member of
my church. Uh, I do teach. I do lead out
in Bible studies. I also, uh, am part of
the personal ministries department. Um,
but currently what I do full-time is I'm
a solar salesperson. So, if anybody's
looking for solar, little, uh, little
cheap, uh, what do you call that? Clip
thing. Um,
little plug.
Little plug. There you go. Little cheap
plug in there. Um, but no, but for real,
um, I'm passionate about the Lord. I'm
passionate about the truth. I'm passion
about the Bible and just sharing his
love with everybody around.
Well, cool. Mike, who are you?
Well, I'm Mike Colburn. I have been a
7th Adventist my entire life until about
four months ago, so 43 years. My dad was
an Adventist pastor his whole life and
career. Is now retired.
Uh we live in Northwest Arkansas. I am
passionate about scripture, biblical ex
Jesus. currently getting my masters in
biblical studies and uh just excited to
have a honest dialogue and conversation
and may may the truth be be known. So
that's a little bit about me. Amen.
Well, thank you both again for being
here. A quick rundown for the audience
and just a refresher for you all on the
agenda for the night.
Each interlocutor will have five minutes
to open to give an overview of their
response to the topic. This will be
followed by one hour of back and forth
discussion which is going to be broken
up into 15minute increments of control
time. What do I mean by control time?
Control time is simply to make sure that
questions are able to be asked and
basically that no filibuster uh
filibustering happens. We want to have a
good rigorous discussion tonight where
both positions are both presented and
examined and then each individual will
have a fivem minute closing to wrap
things up.
I will be functioning as a neutral
moderator facilitating the dialogue and
making sure we stay on subject if we
happen to get off track which is
understandable in these types of
discussions. I will simply step in and
get us back on track. Final point, when
you hear this,
that means you have one minute left.
That will indicate one minute. And then
when you hear it a second time, that
will indicate your time is up. So you
can wrap up your thoughts if you happen
to be in the middle of one when that
dings. But that will ding at the exact
minute. So just finish up your thought
after you hear that the second time. Any
questions?
All right, Matt, we will start with you.
We Oh, go ahead.
Sorry, I thought you said something.
Matt, we are going to start with you. We
did a coin toss and uh Matt is going to
go first. You'll have five minutes to
explain what as an Adventist Let me get
the stopwatch going here. what you as an
Adventist believe the uh role of the ten
commandments is for the Christian. Your
time will begin once you start speaking,
sir.
Okay. Thank you for the time. Uh so I'll
just be kind of more brief than long on
this uh and I'll give a big picture and
then I'll break it down a little bit. So
um I will just answer the question uh
biblically what is the role of the ten
commandments or the law of god in the
life of the believer and really in the
life of humanity. So, um, the big
picture I, uh, concur with with Paul in
Galatians is that it's to bring us to
Christ. Uh, the the the ten commandments
are ultimately to point us to Jesus, uh,
who gives us life and liberty and his
spirit uh, in order to carry out those
principles and those details. uh and
more specifically if you go to Romans 3,
Romans 4, Romans 7, uh you will see that
the law of God actually defines sin and
righteousness. So it gives us the
definition of what sin and righteousness
is. It encompasses the whole duty of our
human race and it is the means by which
God will judge the world. It's also the
basis of God's covenant with all of his
believers. When we go into a covenant
relationship with God, both if you look
at the old and in the new covenant, the
basis of that covenant is the ten
commandments. It is his law. Uh the only
difference between the two, which I'm
sure we'll get into, uh is what is
usually being contrasted in scripture uh
as opposed to it contrasting whether or
not we should uh have the law in our
lives or obey the law or have it
necessary. Um the law has never changed.
It's always binding. And I believe that
as we look into scripture and especially
as we go throughout time and we go in
through the time of the second coming or
through the time of the return of
Christ, we do see that there are a
people that are faithful um to Jesus. We
have the faith of Jesus and they also
are uh they also keep his commandments.
Again, I want to make it clear though
the big picture is that the expression
of our faith or the expression of our
salvation is not what actually gets us
saved. Right? So what saves us is
Ephesians 2:8-10. Right? By grace we are
saved through faith. That is what is our
salvation. That is where our starting
point and our end point is when it comes
to salvation. I confess that the Lord
Jesus Christ is my Lord and Savior and I
believe with all my heart. I am a saved
human being and nobody can take that
away uh from you as long as you are in
Christ. You know all that the father has
given to him or all that yeah all that
the father has given to him will in no
you know will in no wise uh you know can
be removed from that. So however once
you are in that saving relationship and
in that uh established covenant
relationship with the Lord there is a an
expression of that and I'll put it
plainly the expression of it is
obedience. Now how that looks uh can be
varying depending on the situation. Um
so if it is you know in a sense of you
know someone just cut me off on the road
or someone had just cussed me out or
anything like that uh I believe that
that expression of my faith will look
like you know mercy grace and
forgiveness and that is an obedient that
that is obeying I believe in in every
respect the thou shalt not kill in which
Jesus put it into it goes further than
just the actual physical act. it goes
into the actual intention uh and the
holding of that intention to get
someone. So again, big picture, I know
I'm probably going to be running out of
time in a second, but just to give you
the the big picture summary again, the
purpose of God's law, the purpose of the
ten commandments is to lead us to
Christ, who then will uh through his
spirit and through his power, we'll then
be able to carry out the principles of
that law in our daily living. And
depending on the situation, it may look
different.
[Music]
Look at that.
Still got one. Still got one minute,
sir.
No, I'm good. I I I think I'll I'll
stamp it right on there.
Okay. Thank you for that. Mike, same
thing for you. Your five minutes will
start when you begin speaking, sir.
Awesome. Uh thank you guys for the
opportunity. Uh good evening everyone.
Most Christians, as Matt already brought
out, most Christians are going to agree
the law plays an essential role in the
life of a Christian. Uh, the Adventist
position, which I have been an Adventist
for 43 years, not saying I know it all,
but I know quite a bit of it. The
Adventist position regards the Ten
Commandments as an eternal, unchanging
moral law that remains binding on all
Christians, as Matt brought up. This
includes the observance of the Sabbath
on Saturday, which they view as
essential for maintaining a proper
relationship with God. even suggesting
that it is a requirement at least to
maintain your salvation and a mark of
the remnant church. Now, while
Adventists argue that following these
commandments is a response from God's
grace, their insistence that
Sabbathkeeping, for example, is a
necessity for salvation implies a
worksbased
hybrid model or approach to
righteousness. This directly contradicts
the message of the New Testament which
teaches that salvation as again I
appreciate Matt sharing is received by
grace through faith alone in Jesus
Christ not through obedience of the law.
Now I want to be clear about something.
The original purpose of the ten
commandments in its context in the old
testament these laws were given
specifically to the nation of Israel as
the foundation of the old covenant. They
served as a way of defining sin. That's
Romans 5:13. To guide ethical conduct,
Deuteronomy 5. And distinguished the
Israelites from the surrounding pagan
nations. Exodus 31 as well as Ezekiel
20. So these commandments, they played a
a crucial role in shaping the identity
of God's chosen people, and they set the
boundaries for what was considered
righteous behavior underneath the old
covenant. But when the Christ event
occurred, a new covenant was
established. And I firmly believe that
that was not a renewal of the old
covenant. It was a brand new covenant
that allows us to relate differently to
the law. And according to the New
Testament, Jesus fulfilled the law,
including the Ten Commandments. Matthew
5:17 is pretty clear in that. Do not
think that I have come to abolish the
law. I have come to not to abolish it
but to fulfill it. This fulfillment
doesn't mean that the moral principles
necessarily behind the commandments are
discarded
but rather that they find their
completion in Christ's life, his death
and his resurrection. And the
commandments were were not an end in
themselves. They are not the standard by
which we are judged. They actually
pointed us to Christ. they should point
us to Christ who takes away the
condemnation of that law for those who
believe in him. Then Galatians 3:11 is
pretty clear now. It is evident that no
one is justified before God by the law,
for the righteous shall live by faith.
The New Testament makes it abundantly
clear that the law's purpose was to
point out sin and our need for a savior,
but it was never intended to be a means
or a mechanism by which we are saved.
Furthermore, I want to point out that
the new the new covenant emphasizes new
commands. I call them many scholars will
call them the laws of Christ or laws of
the Messiah. Most understand them as
kind of a summarized way of the two
great, you know, the great commandments,
right? Love God with all of your heart,
soul, mind, and love the your neighbor
as yourself. And those are recorded in
Matthew 22:35-4.
But what's interesting is the uh they
summarize this there's this moral shift.
There's this the essence of the law
shifted from a legalistic observance
instead to a heartbased relationship.
And the New Testament also presents
additional directives for Christian life
that are called the laws of Christ or
the laws of Messiah.
So Christ's fulfillment of the law sets
us free from its condemnation, empowers
us to live according to a new law, the
law of love and the law of grace. And
our salvation depends not on any kind of
rigid adherence to commandments that
we're all going to be judged by, but
rather by the faithfulness of Christ and
the inward transformation that the Holy
Spirit brings. Uh the ten commandments,
I do not believe biblically that the ten
commandments are going to be the
standard by which we are all judged as
humanity. Instead, we are judged by the
faithfulness of Jesus Christ. Uh if
you'll look at Galatians 2:16, it's
pretty clear. Yet we know that no one is
justified by the works of the law, but
by the faithfulness of Jesus Christ. And
we have come to believe in Christ Jesus,
so that we may be justified by the
faithfulness of Christ and not by the
works of the law because by the works of
the law, no one will be justified. Just
on that point further, 2 Timothy 2 11-13
is also clear. This saying is
trustworthy. For if we have died with
him, we will also live with him. If we
endure, we will also reign with him. If
we deny him, he also will deny us. If we
are faithless, he remains faithful. So
we can believe in the faithfulness of
Christ. Why? Because he cannot deny
himself. The emphasis must be on living
out of love.
Yes,
time.
We're good. Sorry. I apologize.
Oh, no. You're good. You got you got
about 30 seconds extra there. So, Matt,
would you like 30 seconds extra? Are you
cool on the scripture reading there?
Cool.
Okay. Thank you for that, Mike.
All right. We're going to transition
into our 60-minute discussion period,
which will be broken up, like I said,
into four 15minute increments. Each of
you receiving 30 minutes in total of
control time. Just reiterate, control
time is for you to lead the discussion.
Keyword being discussion. um by asking
questions and examining.
With that said, Matt, the control time
will start with you. The time will start
once you ask your first question to
Mike.
Okay, Mike, I appreciate your
explanation um and thesis there. Um
couple of things. I I think in general I
agree with what you were saying.
However, your your indication that
there's been a shift
at the Christ event, the shift being a
heart relationship versus a letter
relationship. So question for you are is
your understanding that in the Old
Testament or in the Old Covenant and
again correct me if I'm if that's not
your understanding uh or if it's any
point in the biblical narrative um is it
your understanding that there was never
a requirement for them to have that
heart connection?
So how in other words yeah that's the
question I would like to ask.
Yeah I don't I don't think that's the
indication. I think that um
fundamentally I don't think most people
understand the covenantal relationships
in the Old Testament and laws taken
outside of a covenantal relationship
really don't mean anything. Uh there's
there's no real binding effect on anyone
if there's no contract or covenantal
relationship. And so, you know, clearly
the Old Testament talks about, you know,
the law being written on the heart. I
think is Deuteronomy. I think even
references some of that. But that wasn't
the way they engaged. The way they
engaged in a relationship with God under
the Old Testament was through their
law abiding by making sure that they're
dealing with the the laws in a correct
way. And if they didn't, they were cast
out of the the family, so to speak. They
were kicked out.
Go ahead. You were gonna ask another
question.
Yeah. So, um I would I I would say
that's an overgeneralization.
Certainly, not every single character in
the Old Testament had that kind of
relationship. I mean, and you alluded to
it, Deuteronomy 5:29, if uh Miles can
put that up.
Uh and I know that's probably what you
were referring to. Um the you know, oh
that there was such a heart in them that
they would fear me and keep all my
commandments always. So there there
always were that had to be in place
first in order for that to happen.
Right. So and I and I appreciate what
you said because you did say that you
know it was a majority of Israel in the
Old Testament in the majority of their
history was just more of disobedience
than it was obedience.
Right? And that's what got them into a
lot of trouble and that's what got them
into bondage. That's what got them into
these uh you know slaves into these
nations and things like that. Um, but
the intention of God in giving his ten
commandments, right, the intention was
always to have the new covenant
experience. Even in the Old Testament,
God didn't have two ways to save
humanity.
Never did.
If we interpreted it that way, the fault
is on who?
If I if I if we interpreted God had two
ways to save us. one by keeping the
letter of the law and one by, you know,
having a heart connection with him.
Yeah. I don't
I actually don't think that
Yeah. I don't I don't think the plan of
salvation shifted. It's always been in
place and we need we know that by
Hebrews talks about like by faith
Abraham was was made right. So I think
we're talking about two different
things. Um okay, the laws
I just clarify. Yeah. Sorry, I didn't
mean to cut you off. I just I'm I just
wanted to clarify because I wasn't sure
if it was clear on what you were saying
because you had said there's been a
switch at the Christ event and I don't
see
I I I I'm not seeing exactly clear where
you're seeing that switch when that that
whole you know the two laws that Jesus
mentioned you mentioned this too and I
wrote this down love God with all your
heart all your mind all your soul love
uh you know love love each other love
man as you know treat um love your
neighbor as yourself I mean these are in
the Old Testament
Yeah. So, let me let me just try to
explain a little bit further.
So, yeah. So, I just want to hear where
where are you seeing the disconnect
because I don't see a disconnect between
Old Testament and New Testament in terms
of what God required. I do see that
there's a difference between how how you
know what we responded when God was
trying to get the original response
which is the new covenant response.
Yeah. So, so covenantally,
if if you study the covenant
relationship, God engaged with his
people under certain, we we would call
them contracts, certain contractual
arrangements. You see the Noahic
covenant that gets put in place. Um,
very very clear. That's a he says that
I'm never going to destroy the world,
right? So, so there wasn't anything that
Noah needed to do. It's it's what's
called a it's it's not a dual law, you
know, agreement where Noah did
something, God did something back.
That's a it's a unilateral act. Okay?
So, God makes a promise, he follows
through on his promise. Noah gets to
just be a part of the fact that there's
a covenant relationship there. So if you
go through all the covenant
relationship, Abrahamic covenant, Mosaic
covenant, which the Mosaic covenant is
where the Sinai, you know, the ten
commandments along with all 613 laws,
all that goes into place.
So
we're going to break those. Yeah.
Yeah. So So you're gonna you're going to
see that with each of those covenants,
there are a different set or a different
way that either one party or the other
party was required to be engaged. Some
of them are unilateral, some of them are
both. Okay, the Abrahamic covenant is
unilateral. There is nothing that
Abraham had to do in order to be
blessed. Abraham just was that was the
agreement with the covenant. Um, if you
look at the new covenant, the new
covenant actually isn't necessarily a
New Testament covenant. It was actually
predicted in Jeremiah 31 and Ezekiel 36.
So it it specifically says I'm the new
covenant is going to happen. I'm going
to give you a new covenant. Now I think
that the the Jesus event is the
culmination of that new covenant. And
that new covenant was ratified. Every
covenant had to be ratified by blood.
That it was ratified by the blood of
Jesus Christ. So what's the agreement?
What's the contract? Well, you're saved
by faith. There is no works of the law.
Whereas prior to in order to be a part
of the family there was actually very
specific things you had to do.
Circumcision there was very specific
things Levitical laws that had to take
place in order to be a part of that
relationship.
Ask you a question.
Yeah.
Let me let me finish one thought here.
I just wanted
Yeah. If you broke those covenant those
covenant agreements, you were either
killed or you were kicked out of the
camp.
So they're very different when you pull
those.
Okay. Go ahead.
All right. So, um, there's a lot of
things you said there. It wasn't just
one clut. Um, and now I'm kind of Let's
pull up Genesis 17:1.
Okay.
For example. Okay. Genesis 17:1.
Uh, let me pull it up on here as well.
So you were mentioning about Abraham
and it says when Abraham was 99 years
old the Lord appeared to Abraham and
said to him I am God Almighty walk
before me and be blameless or in other
you know translations that's another
word for you know being complete being
perfect uh that I will that I may make
my covenant between me and you and
multiply you greatly so was there a part
to play so just I want to make it here
you you were now okay there's one thing
you did say the unilateral uh aspect
right so in terms of in terms of the the
the the part that God is is playing
right God was the one that is going to
not only make the promise but also carry
the promise out to fulfillment
right that's super clear that's what you
mentioned
Right?
God's purpose in all those covenants.
No, the Noah covenant, you know, I will
not destroy, you know, there's nothing
there that Noah had to, you know, other
than uh, you know, other than believe
Abraham, right? Uh, I will car I I will
do this in my own way. But Abraham
obviously made mistakes trying to carry
out in his own way. And this is why God
had said to him what he said to him in
Genesis 17.
Right. So, in other words, Abraham
actually had an old covenant experience
in the midst of his narrative. Do you
agree or not agree?
I don't know what you mean by the old
covenant. I'm not sure I'm following.
Four compares the two the two children.
[Music]
Who did Isaac uh sorry, who did Ishmael
represent? What kind of covenant did
Ishmael represent? What kind of
experience did Ishmael represent?
Well, I think we're I mean
We're we're getting into sort of like
interpretation of it. Like fun
fundamentally the Abrahamic covenant and
its conditions is understood as a
unilateral
covenant where God made a promise. There
was nothing that Abraham needed to do.
It was all God.
They needed to let God do his thing.
There there was there was no part of I
mean I don't know how to
so what how do you harmonize what you're
saying with Genesis 17:1 I'm not saying
that Abraham is the one that is going to
carry out and make the promise happen
but there's certainly a part we play in
this in in this experience and that's
surrender and in allowing the spirit of
God to do its thing
but that but that's not the way covenant
agreements worked in the ancient near
east framework So there's nothing
there's nothing that Abraham was
required to do. Yeah. Okay. He walked
before God and God but God did
everything. There was nothing that
correct.
Correct. I I'm agreement with God did
everything and including in when you
mentioned now in the and so all
covenants actually right there was no so
there's no new covenant or different
covenant from all these covenants.
Essentially God is doing everything
including the old covenant. However, the
reason why it's called the old covenant
was in the in this respect is that the
people started to put themselves as a
party to it as opposed to just God
having to be a party to it,
right? Because if you look at the new
covenant, God is doing the same thing he
wanted them to have experience of. He
wanted them to experience himself in a
heart relationship, right? He wanted
them to have that, hey, it's not us that
we can do this in our own strength and
our own power. It is the Lord that is
going to carry this out for us. And many
times you have that experience with
Israel as a nation when they went to go
fight battles with other nations that
sometimes they didn't do anything and
let the Lord fight before them. And that
was a new covenant experience. These
were all examples of that. Now you
mentioned all these laws as well. Uh in
the satic you mentioned the 613 laws.
You know you can just kind of in uh so
there's a couple of things with that
right.
Number one these laws are divided into
four different laws. four different
sections, right? You have the moral law,
you got the ceremonial law, you got
civil laws, which are called statutes
and judgments, and you have hygienic
laws.
As long as Israel was a sovereign
nation, they were required to keep the
statutes and judgments.
That's why now they are no longer under
a, you know, theocracy. They are no
longer under a sovereign, they're not a
sovereign nation on themselves, led by
directly by God, where they can carry
out these things because they're subject
to the laws of the land that they're in.
right? When they were in Babylon, when
they were in Persia, when they were in
Greece, when they were under Rome, they
could not I mean, Rome gave a little
bit, but they could not just uh
autonomously and authoritatively carry
out their statutes and judgments. In
other words, if someone broke the
Sabbath, they couldn't just stone them
to death. If someone was caught in
adultery, they couldn't just stone them
to death. That's why today when people
when men are cheating on their wife or
wife are cheating on their husband, you
don't see death penalty enacted. We are
no longer under that kind of uh
sovereign government. We're under the
laws of government we're in. We're under
the laws of the United States in this
example, right? Where where
is there a I'm just curious. Is there a
question that you have with regards to
So I'm just I'm I'm I'm I'm kind of
reclarifying because you had brought you
make these up and I'm I wanted to you
know see what your exchange was on that.
Um, but again clearly what I'm trying to
ask you is you're saying that when know
going back to the original question when
Christ came there was a change
and a change by who?
By the fact that Christ says there's a
new covenant ratified by like he's the
one that says about he talks about it.
He's the one that instituted the new
covenant. it it's his statement that and
it's it's a prophetic fulfillment of
both Jeremiah and what did I say Ezekiel
or like it was prophesied that someone
would come
and that he he is the like he's the one
that talks Jesus is the one that talks
about it we can go to it I I can pull it
up I I I wanted to before I go there
because I you were asking or you were
stating something about the divisions of
the law Um
was there a question that you had with
regards to that like that you wanted
one minute left
and that's okay and again I was the one
asking no I was I was just kind of
clarifying because um you had made it in
passing uh as that being
because I would of the covenant that God
was
fundamentally disagree personally I
would disagree that there was divisions
of the law. Now some might okay this is
actually a debate in scholarship.
I don't think there is any in the Jewish
writings in the actual Hebrew scriptures
there is no way that they felt the law
was separated. It was a unit. It was one
unit. Yes, there were certain you as a
modern individual could look at it and
claim that there are ways that you could
break it up into certain ways of seeing
them. But there was the same just like
it said in it says in James, if you
broke one, you broke them all. It's one
unit.
So I I would fundamentally disagree that
you you can't break and we can talk
about that. I'll ask some questions
probably on that, but I don't think
that's a healthy way of looking at the
law.
All right, gentlemen. That was the first
15 minutes. We will now reverse roles
for another 15 minutes. Don't worry,
Matt. It will be swinging back to you
for another goround. But Mike, the
control time is now yours. The time will
start once you begin speaking, sir.
Awesome. Matt, what is how is a person
made right with God?
Sorry, I'm trying to write some
responses what you were saying. Okay.
Uh, a person is made right with God by
believing in Christ. I believe in Romans
4, it he believed in God and to him was
imputed righteousness.
Okay. Is there anything else that makes
a person right with God?
I believe that once that experience
happens, God has the law written in
their heart and that and the righteous
fulfillment of the law is also the
righteous requirement of the law are
fulfilled in them as well. In other
words, God not only just not God just so
in other words, there's two parts to
that. It's you're declared and then
you're and then you're also made.
Okay?
Right? I believe in the Lord Jesus,
declared righteous. Romans 4. And then
you go to Romans 8. I'm also walking in
the spirit and I'm being also made
righteous in my life going forward.
Okay. So if I hear you right,
you are made right by faith, but then
now that you believe, now you
I don't want to say you're required, but
it you're you're going to do something
because of your faith.
I I I will I will refer to Philippians
chapter 2
and I will go to uh verse
13.
Okay. So you understand that to be a
part of a salva salvational aspect
working out the way that you are made
right with God.
So once again my expression of salvation
is not what saves me.
Okay. So then let me then what saves
you?
Being in Christ, believing in the Lord
Jesus as my savior. As my Lord and
Savior, accepting him as as Yeah.
accepting him as my savior. Accepting
his life in exchange for my life.
Okay. So, okay, I agree with that. Um,
with that assumption, I need something
clarified. Since we're made right by
belief in Christ, then why do the
Adventist theology teach that you are
judged
by the standard of the Ten Commandments?
If you're made right with God, by your
faith, why are you being judged by your
works, by by the law, by the
commandments?
Yeah. So, judgment and salvation are not
exactly the same, although you're trying
to make them. Are you trying to make
them synonymous when we express it that
way or when it's expressed that way?
I'm asking how you how you deal with the
discrepancy between that? Because if
you're if you're saved by the fa by your
faith in Christ,
then why would a person be judged by
something else other than your faith in
Christ?
I mean, you'd have to ask James. Uh
you'd have to ask Paul. Uh I would say
that James uh makes it very clear
that it is in the way and the way again
I'm not just to be facitious here but
the way I the way I express and the way
I understand it is that the judgment on
our works or the judgment on uh you know
keeping the commandments of God or
anything like that is it's not that
that's what saves us. It's an expression
of whether or not so like the way I'll
let me put it this way. Good works
doesn't save you.
Bad works doesn't save you either. I
mean, sorry, it doesn't unsave you.
So then why are you judged by him?
Bad works doesn't unsave you. What those
works are showing it's whether or not
you actually had genuine faith.
Okay. So followup question.
Let me ask a follow.
Was that was that did that answer your
question? satisfactory. Was that clear?
Is that Do you not see that as
I I understand what you're saying. Um
seems a little confusing to me, but I
think I think I understand.
Can I can I please just recclarify my
answer? Right. Are you are you are
married? I'm assuming. Or if not, I'm
not sure. But you said your wife. Yes.
So, you're married. Um and uh
there are bad marriages, there are good
marriages, there are happy marriages,
there are sad marriages, right?
Mhm.
Um does the fact that you said I do and
put the ring on and uh you know does
that does that then encompass the entire
marriage relationship meaning does that
take the place of whether or not a
marriage does that determine whether or
not a marriage is happy or sad or good
or bad? What determines a happy
marriage? What determines a bad
marriage?
Well, I'm not sure where you're going
with this because I'm not seeing how
this says
basically saying to you is that how you
express
that marriage determines whether or not
it's a bad or good marriage. Bad or good
relationship. How it's expressed.
So, it has nothing to do with the
faithfulness that Christ expressed.
That is what I'm saying. Fa Yeah.
Faithfulness to Christ expressed is
obedience. And that
so so here here's what I think that this
is what I'm trying to understand. It it
feels like
go ahead. Sorry I don't mean to cut you.
Go ahead.
It feels like the standard by which
someone is saved because the fundamental
beliefs are very clear. They state in
the fundamental beliefs that you are
saved by grace through faith. But in the
very next paragraph, the expectation is
yes, except
you're judged by something different. So
there there's I don't understand the how
do you reconcile being judged by a
standard that is different than what is
required for salvation.
Okay. The standard is an expression.
It's it's it's just mapping out how God
is using an expression of our covenantal
relationship with him. I mean, if we go
into Hebrews 10 or Hebrews 8, when we go
into the new covenant, I mean, that's
exactly what it says. When you're in the
covenant relationship with the Lord,
it's going to be expressed as someone
who has internalized his law and is
carried out in the life.
So, are you saved, Matt?
I am saved.
I believe by faith I am saved.
Do you always express that? Do you
always express that you are following
the ten commandments?
So in my own mind and conscience
I have a I I express that
um
I don't want to get too into the
personal question because I can see
where you're veering off of it. That's
fine. But
I'm not going to use an anecdotal
question like that as to I mean I'm just
stating with what the scripture says. I
mean the purpose of this is what is the
role of the purpose of the command of
God.
So let's be clear. You're stating your
interpretation of the scripture. Your
your interpretation of it is what you're
stating.
I no an expression of the scripture. The
Christ obeys through me.
Okay. But here here is the problem that
I see. He
gets the glory. He gets the credit. He
obeys in me. Right
now, I do believe also just to again
continue to answer is that anyone who's
in a saving relationship with Christ is
not going to come to the conclusion and
sit there and say that, you know, I
perfectly obey him at every hour and
every moment and every day. And we need
him every moment and every day. That's
how it's going to be expressed. Hey, I
am nothing. He is everything. Right? I I
don't have in my own strength or in my
own knowledge
that I have the power to carry out his
principles without him. It must be him
doing it in and through me. That's my
belief. That's what I stand on.
Okay. So,
thank you for sharing that.
Yeah.
Thank you for sharing that. Let me ask a
follow-up question to that. Um,
does that imply then by what you're
saying that if you or I struggle
with a certain commandment in word,
thought, or deed that in some way I am
not I'm lacking faith or lacking
maturity because it sounds like if I'm
if I'm fully in Christ, then how am I
going to express it? I'm going to
perfectly emulate
the law as an expression of my
obedience. So, does that mean that if I
don't and I sin,
which scriptures clear that all have
sinned and fallen short of the glory of
God, does that mean that now I'm not
saved?
So, I would say let's take the focus off
of you so much and focus on Christ in
those areas that you feel you're uh you
know going against him.
Well, but the the standard the
fundamental belief believes that you're
going to be judged by the ten
commandments. So, if I'm struggling with
a particular commandment
then
I I I I would defer to the topic at
hand, right? What is the role of the ten
commandments? What is the role of the
law of God in life? And your answer is
I have a problem with that. We're judged
by that.
Well, I would fundamentally state that
we're not judged by it. But well, we're
judged by the faithfulness of Christ.
We're not judged by the ability of a
human to keep a standard that was
required for the Israelites and not
required for us today. But um
does so does the does the faithfulness
of Christ not transfer into our lives?
Yes. But under the new covenant
arrangement. Yes.
I I agree.
So So is it your understanding that the
new covenant is just a renewal of the
ten commandments?
No. Uh my understanding is that the new
covenant is
Christ in me. the hope of glory and that
it's all him and zero me.
So then why am I okay? This is why I'm
confused on what you're saying like
that. It's it's it's me. It's it's if
anything is that if that is happening in
my life, uh it is because I because of
the indwelling spirit of Christ in me,
right? He gets the glory. It's it's his
obedience. It's his faith living out
through me. And you know the you know I
believe Hebrews 4 it's like you know the
work the work is to not get in the way
of that.
The work is not to work. The work is not
to get in the way of God's work in you.
Um you know we can go to 1 John 2:1.
Uh you know you had mentioned you know
all have sinned and fall short of the
glory. Of course and we are all sinners
in need of Christ in the grand scheme of
the plan of salvation. Our part is just
like Abraham's part and that's to
believe.
But see that does okay I agree. The
problem is is that the follow up to that
inside the advent system followed by
your standard by something different.
Okay.
You're judged based on whether or not
you believed or not.
Okay. I'm okay with that. But that's not
the ideology
that that that I'm summarizing it and
generalizing it. Right? Now, let me ask
you a question.
Let's take the where this is coming
from. Right? Because this this all comes
from Abraham. Meaning what we said about
hey, you know, you want to do the works
of God, you know, be like Abraham,
believe, right? Mhm.
When Abraham took Hagar
and created Ishma,
did Abraham express belief or disbelief,
but none of that had anything to do with
the fact that he was faithful.
Just answer the question. Did Abraham
express belief or disbelief when he took
Hagar and made a child through Hagar?
Mike, it's technically your control
time. So, I just want to remind that and
put that put that out there.
Yeah. Yeah. I think you're going down a
direction that doesn't follow the point
of the covenant and doesn't follow the
like there's a this is where I this is
where I get really struggle with. It's
very convoluted in the mind of of what
saves but what doesn't save and then
judgment and this and you're judged by
this and not that. And so let me just
ask in let me let me go down another
direction here real quick. Okay. Um in
your opening statements you mentioned um
and this is in the fundamental beliefs
as well that uh that the ten
commandments are eternal and binding on
all humanity.
And I think that that is obtained by
Exodus 316 and 17 I think is where that
usually is is taken. And uh Miles, if
you want to put that on the screen, you
can.
Um, but fundamentally, do do you I just
want to hear just make sure I'm
understanding. Do you believe that the
Ten Commandments are eternally binding
on all humans?
I want Yeah. I I when I say binding,
meaning it's it's it's still in effect.
Okay. And the law Yeah. What I mean by
that is that the law of God, the ten
commandments law of God was never
abolished.
Okay. So in that verse that was on the
screen, the reference there is that it's
a covenant forever. So it says that in
there observing the Sabbath throughout
all generations as a covenant forever.
And I think this number one I think this
is important because the Sabbath becomes
very important inside of you know that
this whole conversation around covenant
and the fact that this olam the Hebrew
word olam for forever is used here to
interpret like oh it's it's it's
eternally binding. So here's my
question.
If that's the case, why then
are the other five instances where this
same covenantal forever word language is
being used? Why are they not still
binding? Circumcision, the Passover, the
day of atonement, feast of tabernacles,
and the Levitical priesthood. All the
same language.
Okay, we'll come back to it.
Okay.
All right, gentlemen. You guys are doing
excellent here. I really appreciate the
rigorous back and forth here. Matt, we
are back to you for control time for 15
minutes. Your final set here. Let Mike
get comfortable there. And you know the
rules. When you ask or begin asking your
first question, your time will start.
All right. I I'd like to go back to this
Abraham uh experience. Uh could you
answer the question that I posed
earlier? When Abraham took Hagar and
made her a child with her, was Abraham
was that an expression of belief in the
covenant?
Uh, no. But let me follow up with the
fact that the Abrahamic covenant was
unilateral. So there was nothing that
Abraham could have done or not done to
change the reality covenant.
That's not the question. The question is
if Abraham were to be in a sense uh you
know because in a sense what you're what
we're doing when we're reading these
characters I mean we're you know in a
sense judging them right um you know not
in a sense condemning them but we're
like we're assessing like hey this is
acceptable this is not acceptable
behavior or this is acceptable uh way to
live this is not an acceptable way to
live do you believe that there is a
standard on how to live uh as a believer
in
Yes, but that standard is not a part of
your salvation.
I didn't ask that. I know it's I didn't
say that it was. Like I said, again, I
want to make it very clear to the
everybody that's going to be watching
this later on. I don't want this to be,
you know, taken out of context and
clipped out of what I said. I want to be
absolutely clear.
The expression of our faith is not what
saves us.
And I think what's going on here with a
lot of you know a lot of the conf you
know a lot of this you know with between
non-adventists or you know is the fact
that they're they are they are they are
in this false sense of theology that
they think that we teach which we don't
right that you're saved by works
this is not Catholicism I don't believe
that in one bit
but there is a distinction that there is
a but do you not believe that there's a
do you believe that there's going to be
a separation in is there a separation in
in any judgment of Christ? I mean, you
look at the parables in Matthew 25, it's
pretty clear there's a separation
between two groups of two people.
So, is there a qu So, is there a
question or like because
Okay. So my question to you was when
because you had explained it so I had to
you know go over your explanation but
the question is in the experience of
Abraham right
he did not express belief
when he took Hagar
okay
but he expressed belief
when he waited for God's timing with
Sarah.
Okay. So, what what's the question?
You have a question for him, Matt?
Oh, I just wanted to I just wanted to
ask if that was an expression of
disbelief or not. And you did answer it.
It was Yes, it was an expression of
disbelief.
So, yes, but I want the audience to
understand that the covenant
relationship with Abraham and Yahweh was
unilateral. So, it wouldn't have
mattered how Abraham did certain things.
It was all God. So just because he
expressed unbelief did not change the
promise that's in the covenantal
relationship that between Yahweh and his
descendants that we are now all be being
able to be a part of because of the fact
that Christ came and everything that
happened.
Okay.
His faith was not dependent on God
blessing.
Okay.
That's the point here.
How um how does condemnation who who's
going to get condemned?
Those who do not believe in Jesus Christ
and the faithfulness that he was a
perfect
blameless lamb slain for us.
Okay. Um and how is that expressed?
Can you go to John?
How is what expressed?
How is not accepting the sacrifice of
Christ expressed? Can someone go to John
3:1 19? Can we go there?
I mean, it's expressed by unbelief is
the way it's expressed.
Okay. How is that carried out? How's
that unbelief carried out? Can we go to
John 3:19? Can you read that?
And this is the judgment. The light has
come into the world and the people loved
the darkness rather than the light
because their works were evil.
Okay. So, in this text, how are what's
the description of the works of those
that are in darkness and con and and uh
I know it says judgment, the con and
condemned in the context of
condemnation.
Yeah. So, so first of all, I want to be
very careful because I really hate going
to one text and I'm not sharing the
context of everything that's going on
here. So this is I I'd be really careful
to start making a distinction where it
just because it says the words were evil
does not mean that the works that are
being described here is like
simple question for you uh Mike
does belief
uh
preede the works
in that context let's let's do a
contextual observation of John 3.
Yeah. But belief has belief everything
to do with your salvation.
Your works do not have anything to do
with your salvation. Yes. There is an
expression of your faith. I get that.
Yes. But in in the Adventist system,
those two are married together.
Listen, you keep thinking Adventist. We
can have a listen. We can have a part
two where we can talk about the
Adventist doctrines. Let's let's let's
let's get into the Bible because I don't
believe there's a contradiction here and
I'm trying to explain to you how it is
expressed biblically which is where we
get these ideas from.
Go ahead.
Okay. So, so my so I don't want again
I'm supposed to be asking the questions,
right? So the the question was does
belief
precede
the works
and your answer was yes you did I just
want to clarify for everybody you did
say
works
with regards to your belief in Christ
yeah I mean you're there are going to be
works that you do after you believe in
Christ
all I'm saying and all I' all we're
saying as Adventists but again we're not
trying to again I love my my the reason
why I'm that's just give you one reason
why I'm a seventh day adventist is
because of the doctrines and I do
believe they're 100% biblically
biblically biblically proofed right um
so according to this text your belief is
going to be either expressed in you know
uh it's going to come it's going to
result in condemnation or it's going to
result in if you go to the verse before
obviously especially in 16 uh or
salvation
right you that that's absolutely clear.
Hey, your belief is going to result in
either eternal life or it's going to
result into condemnation. Correct?
Yes. Your belief is what determines
that. Yes.
So all I'm Yeah. So that's nothing.
We're not saying anything different. All
we're saying is that hey,
God has a there's a there's so do you
not Okay. Now let me ask you another
question.
Does God have a standard or a way
written down or in any kind of example
within the Bible? Is there a way that
God has kind of said and clarified? How
does a uh what is a what does the belief
in
let me put it this way uh how do these
two beliefs disbelief and belief what do
they look like? Does God have any say in
what that looks like?
Yeah, he talks about there there's a lot
of places that talk about unbelief.
Can we go to Ecclesiastes chapter 12?
And I know you're familiar with this
verse.
Yeah.
Can we go to Ecclesiastes 12 and let's
go to
So ju just while you're going there, I I
don't I'm not getting a lot of
questions. I'm getting a lot of like you
telling me kind of what it is. So, I
mean, I'd like to be able to respond to
questions that you
Okay. Okay. So, let's let's let's All
right. So the reason why I wanted to go
to Ecclesiastes chapter 12 is because
it's just saying exactly what we've been
what I've been saying. And I think
you're saying the same thing. I just
think you have an issue
with the expression of what your belief
looks like. And again, we're not we're
not saved by the expression. I want to
make that clear.
Okay.
But there is an you have a question that
I can respond to.
Yeah. What would have happened if
Abraham didn't take Sarah? What would
have happened?
I have no idea. No idea because it did
that's not what happened. So I don't
know. That's just assuming. So I have no
idea.
Well, we we we know it. We kind of we
don't have any clues. Didn't he not take
Sarah before?
No, I have no idea. Scripture does not
tell that that happened.
So what happened when Abraham took
Hagar? Was God's covenant
impeded? Was God's covenant
I have a question. I want like
Yes, I'm asking you.
Okay. The qu the answer is no. He he did
not he he took Sarah.
Yes, he did take others as well. But I
don't know what your question is. Where
are you going? Because again, my problem
with this, and here's my issue with a
lot of what happens inside the Adventist
framework.
The Abrahamic covenant
is not the same as the new covenant.
You can't use one covenant and then
apply that ideology to something else to
make it work. That was a an agreement
between Abraham and between his seed and
his descendants and it was unilateral.
So yes, that is a relationship, but that
is not the same thing as the Mosaic
covenant, which is what the Ten
Commandments is instituted in. So it's
not the same. There's no like I I don't
understand how that's being applied. And
this is fundamentally what what I have
learned is most Adventists haven't done
enough study in covenantal theology and
what it was like in the ancient near
east and why contracts were written
between gods and between the entity that
was in the relationship and that gets
skewed when we bring that ideology into
our modern way of understanding.
Let me let me ask you a question. Can
you give us a summary in about 30
seconds of what that is?
What do you mean by that? You read it up
like about two or three times. What What
is the understanding in your an
understanding of the covenantal eastern?
Uh
okay.
So laws were only used, it's no
different than today, inside of a
relationship between two entities.
In the ancient near east, in the Old
Testament, most of the covenantal
relationships are between Yahweh and
between a group. Okay? It's no different
than today's arrangements. You and I
abide by laws and regulations as US
citizens. This is not weird, right? You
break the law.
Let me finish. Let me finish.
Well, I just want to make sure I'm
keeping up with you. So, so I just want
to summarize what you said. So you're
saying that in the eastern mind of
covenants that the covenant uh is
between two parties. That's what you're
basically saying. An agreement between
two parties.
Yes. And they can be unilateral or they
can be both were required to do
something. Okay. In to
say that's different. And you're saying
that's different in the new covenant.
Well, let me let me finish what's going
on. Okay. So each covenant, whether it's
the Noahic, whether it's the Davidic,
whether it's the Mosaic, the Sinai
covenant, or the new covenant,
the way that the law or the agreement is
written and how it's ratified and what
parties are involved are different or
potentially a an extension of the
previous one.
The problem is is that there is nowhere
in the new covenant that's ratified by
the blood of Jesus that scripture says
that the ten commandments, let alone the
613. Okay, let's just forget the fact
that you're ripping out all the other
603. Okay. But there is no place that
says that the Ten Commandments are a
part of that new covenant ratified by
the blood of Jesus that now is going to
be the standard by which you're either
in or out.
There's nowhere.
The standard by which you're in and out
of the covenant is the is is Christ is
acceptance of Christ.
Correct. But that's not what that's not
what the Adventist theology teaches.
You're absolutely right. But that isn't
Yes, it is. And if you look at, and
again, we'll go back to Abraham's
experience. Um,
did Paul use Abraham's experience to
explain the righteousness by faith? Did
he use Abraham's experience to explain
this kind of
anecdotal covenantal uh example?
Yeah.
For us today, right? Use it heavily. So,
as well as James.
Sure.
Okay. Um
did Paul also
express that there will be
um and again let me ask lead on to it
right uh so you don't think there is a
judgment for
Christians for believers you believe
that judgment already happened
Um,
no. I'm not sure where you're going on
that. I mean, there Yeah, we're there's
a difference between judgment for our
reward versus asking that just to get to
the point because I want everybody to be
clear on this and and this way it gets
kind of like pulls out the whole thing
is that you're stating that there's a
difference in
you're saying that there is no judgment
or there is a judgment but there's no
difference between judgment and
salvation.
I'm saying that we are judged
by our faithfulness
to believing that Christ was faithful.
That is our that is how we are judged
from a salvation standpoint. There is a
difference between rewards
because there are passages that talk
about rewards
versus salvation.
And avenists don't really have a great
great way of
expressing that like for them everything
is about salvation. It's all and part of
the reason why I'm I'm picking you're
expressing it.
Okay. But let me let me just do you
believe that Ellen White is actually
like
well t time Mike before we get off on
that time gentlemen wanted to try and
let you finish that thought there. All
right final 15 minutes. You guys are
doing really good. This is really good
back and forth. I hope you guys are
enjoying yourselves. 15 minutes will
start for you Mike to control the time
when you begin asking your first
question before we then transition into
closing statements.
Okay. So before we ended the last one I
was bringing up the idea of the
eternality of the law which I I think I
understand that you believe that the ten
commandments are eternally binding on
all humanity. So my question was
why or what authority do Adventists have
to exclude all the other instances where
eternal covenant language is used for
things like circumcision Genesis 17 the
Passover Exodus 12 the day of atonement
Leviticus 16 the feast of tabernacles
Leviticus 23 and the Levitical
priesthood which is Exodus 29. Why are
those excluded?
But yet the same language for the Ten
Commandments is used and yet you just
decide that that's the one that is
eternally binding.
Okay, good question. Um, and I'm glad
you asked that because I did want to get
into this. Uh, number one, the New
Testament specifically says those ended
where
but the Ten Commandments are written in
the heart. Where where does where does
it say that those are ended?
Uh we can go into Colossians 2 I believe
and go into
believe Ephesians 2 as well. Believe
those two state that.
So is it your understanding that all of
those even though they're a part of that
same covenant relationship that we were
talking about all of those that we
talked about are a part of
Colossians 2:14-16.
Okay. By cancelelling the record of debt
that stood against us with its legal
demands. Okay.
Okay. So let let me ask a follow-up
question. So your understanding of this
so so so but again you know and again I
want to give a bigger answer because I
did want to address these 613 laws and
why I categorize them into what they are
and that's what they are. Um there are
civil laws which are called statutes and
judgments.
Okay, that's under a sovereign nation
that that no longer exist.
Therefore, those laws are no longer
binding.
And keep in mind that those statutes and
judgments again I'm giving the answer
here were an expression
uh or a specific detailed giving details
of how the principles of the ten
commandments map out into the daily
social life. So you have no so you have
no problem taking those out of because
and the reason why I'm asking this okay
is if the audience goes to Exodus 20
where the commandments are given if you
reading Exodus 20 21 22 23 all of those
are given in the same covenant
relationship all of them there is no
exclusion going on there is no like this
is separate from that and this holds to
this okay they're all a part of the
covenant relationship at Si that Yahweh
made with the Israelites. All of them.
So, by what authority do you have to
extract all the others and rip them all
out when you're not doing the same thing
to the Ten Commandments?
Uh Deuteronomy 4:13
specifically mentions the ten
commandments being his covenant which he
wrote upon two table two tables of
stone.
Okay but you understand that was the
second iteration of the so that was the
second time it was given. If you go back
to Exodus which is Exodus 20
and just we don't have time to read it
all. Okay.
All right. Let's let's let's go into New
Testament because I know you're going to
you're going to you're going to keep
repeating that in the Old Testament keep
saying that all these things or all
these things are part but here's but
here's the reason why here's why I
here's why I say this because if God
didn't make a distinction then I
wouldn't have a a justification for it.
Okay. Um Hebrews chapter se uh sorry
Romans Romans 7 right 7:14
talks about a spiritual law.
Mhm.
Okay. When you go to Hebrews 9, it also
talks about a carnal law.
Uh Hebrews 9:10.
I don't know if you want to I don't know
if you can put parallel verses, uh
Miles, on the screen. If you can put
Romans 7:14 with Hebrews 9:10 at the
same time, it would be really good if
you can do that. If you can't, that's
fine.
We cannot.
Okay.
Uh, so if the Bible didn't give us the
reason to do that, then I wouldn't have
a reason to do that.
So, so you're interpreting, let me go to
Roman, let me go to the Romans one real
quick. So, you said it was Romans 7:14,
just so I understand what you're trying.
That's context of the ten commandments,
by the way.
Okay. So, so let me ask the question on
this. So are you claiming that the Greek
word for commandment here in Romans 7:13
I think it is
that that that word there for
commandment 14
that is a reference
Mike Romans 7:14
okay for we know that the law is
spiritual so okay
right prior to that it's talking about
the commandment right so are you
referring to that the law here is only
the ten commandments.
Is that what you're saying?
I'm saying that I'm saying that Paul
mentioned the seventh commandment in uh
in context here. So it is yes.
He also talked about the law holy, just
and good in verse 12.
Okay. So So here's here's my here would
be my challenge for you. And I don't
know what your
10th commandment sorry 10 tenth
commandment with verse seven.
Yeah. So so here here's where I get
really
um
so you don't if you don't know Greek
it's really easy to have word
association here and just to think that
that Paul is talking about like one
I actually so just so you know I have a
theology degree um as well
that's fine but
I do I do know a little bit of Greek. I
mean, I haven't studied it in a long
time in terms of like, you know,
consistently like it's a task. Um, but
also keep in mind too that the context
is what defines the words as well. It's
not just an isolation of language. Yeah.
Right. So, this plays to what we were
talking about about the Mosaic Sinai
covenant. That entire 613 laws inside of
that covenant are all one unit. The
Jewish nation did not understand
that. Oh, no. It's just the 10. Like,
that's the only thing. So, when Paul is
referring to this here, I do agree that
he's referring to in verse 14 when it
says the law, I do agree that this is
the Mosaic law system, but I think it is
a great misuse of scripture to claim
that it's only the tent. That that that
misunderstanding.
Let me ask you a question. Um, Mike, and
I know I'm supposed to be answering the
question, but I'll let you finish your
statement, but I I I prefer if you ask,
you know, questions and you're making
statements.
That's my question was, do you
understand the word inle the Greek word
here for inle, which is commandment, and
then law?
Your your original question was where
where am I why am I taking away the 603
and leaving the
and I gave you scripture answers for
that.
So, you think that Romans
So, what's your followup? I'm saying
that yeah there's no other law mentioned
here in Romans 7 besides the ten
commandments that I mean the only law
you find here thou shalt not covet and
everything else is you know and
regarding lust is all in the ten
commandments
okay so so just to understand and for
the audience that's watching your
interpretation of what Paul is saying
here is that when he uses the word in
tole he's only referring he's knocking
all the others out and he's only
referring to the ten commandments here
there. Okay. So,
this is so this is why this is so
interesting because okay there are many
places in the Bible including in the New
Testament and Old Testament where it
defines everything as one law.
Mhm.
But there also time but there also
distinctions as well and context is
what's going to determine that.
Okay. Sometimes you see the circumcision
as referred to as the law of the Lord.
because it was obviously authored by God
himself authored that to you know for
Moses to write that but there is a
distinction within that between these
laws there are ceremonial civil hygienic
laws there are moral laws the moral law
cannot be punished by civil authorities
we can't we can't punish for morality in
a sense yes when it comes to stealing
and all
But the moral law in in a in a sense is
going to be dealt with in the judgment,
right? That's where God's going to do
it. So, so what what I'm saying is that
yes, there are many cases where the
Bible is using an example that they are
all one. But in this context, if you had
to sit there and say, well, which law is
this talking about? It's specifically
talking about the Ten Commandments.
There's still a difference in terms of
one part being spiritual and one part
being ceremonial or carnal.
Yeah. So, so this is where this is where
I think so, so this is what it feels
like on the other side. Just so you
know,
is just one law.
Yeah. So, so what it what that feels
like on the other side from an
exogetical standpoint is that it's okay
to pick and choose which one is and
isn't and what's happening and what
isn't.
No, that's why you have to go. Whereas
Paul being a Jew
was actually not referring to like only
this sect or this group or this small.
It's all this is what the fundamental
thing. The Jewish nation did not
understand the law system that they were
under as a segregated law. It was all
What's your next question? Because I
feel like I answered it. And just for
the audience clarity guys, everybody
watching this, context determines, not
my feeling, not your feeling, not how
you feel about the verse or the text.
Paul mentions the tenth commandment in
verse 7. Context determines what we are
looking at. Okay? Paul is not some
Chinese fortune cookie just reiterating
random things and then we just up to us
to figure it out. He actually can give
you verse by verse an understanding of
what he means. And if you don't
understand or read the context, you're
going to not you're going to have these,
you know, great ideas, but just not
biblical, which is what I believe you're
I believe you're in that zone right now.
Yeah. Yeah. And and I know I'm supposed
to ask questions, but I feel like I need
to respond because that what you're
stating might sound great, but it's
actually a misuse of the actual text
because
Paul is talking about the Mosaic system
laws, not about like just the 10 that he
wouldn't even understand segregating
them out. So I understand context does
define
Okay. Can you can you
but
what what I'm trying to clarify here is
that the ten commandments were never
given outside of all 613. Never. There's
never a place where they're given
outside of all the other Levitical laws,
unclean clean laws, sacrificial laws,
all the other laws were all a part of
the covenant. But the Adventist theology
likes to rip all the other ones out and
only deal with the 10. And here and
here's my follow-up question because I'm
going to go to a question. Okay.
Yeah, let's go to questions because I
know that was because that's incorrect
what you said.
So, the fundamental beliefs the
fundamental beliefs outline that the 7th
day advenist system for tithes and
offerings
which are all built on the Levitical
model that was actually given by Ellen
White and in her kind of ordained stamp
for it. How do you respond when a system
of giving which is required? It's part
of the belief system. It's an it's an
obligation for an avenist to tithe.
How do you respond to the fact that that
is based on the Levitical law that is
done away with in your own framework?
Uh so
again your question regarding
reiterate the question again just
because I was looking.
Go ahead. Sorry say one more time.
fundamental beliefs outlined the seventh
adventist system of tithes and offerings
which is based on the Levitical model
for tithes and offerings. How do you
respond to the argument that this system
is rooted in the old covenant which is
no longer an obligation? You're saying
that all those laws and you can also
respond to clean and unclean as well.
Yeah. So I'm going to say that this is
not on the topic of our discussion. The
topic is what is the role or the purpose
of the ten commandments?
I understand you want to commandments.
Okay. But we're talking about the ten
commandments.
Okay.
All right. Let's figure
So we can listen I'm happy to come back
on. We can do another part and discuss
tithing and discuss all of that. And
I read your responses that we've been
I want to stay on topic and I'd
appreciate if our moderator kept us
there as well. we we want to stay with
the with with the topic at hand why
everybody tuned in. So the irony on that
is that we were talking about all the
other things as well for quite some
time, but then when I pressured you on
this particular question, all of a
sudden it wasn't something relevant.
Again, you're bringing in outside
topics. We didn't bring in the outside
topics. I mean, you asked about why are
we as Adventist or why do I determine
that in the new covenant, it's talking
about the ten commandments and not the
other. So let me ask you I I heard the
bell. I know we have one minute. You're
the one asking questions. I think we're
going to be
30 seconds.
Um,
if I can break the rule, I mean, what
laws are in the new covenant,
the laws of Christ?
What is that?
They're all laid out in the gospels.
Love, grace, how we how we treat other
people, all that stuff is laid out. But
the one law that isn't laid out is the
Sabbath command.
[Music]
It's not nowhere in there. All right,
gentlemen.
Gentlemen, I know we could probably go
for another hour. This has been a good
lively discussion. I appreciate both of
you guys being here. This was uh this
was good. Um this was good. So again,
thank you guys for both being here.
Matt, we'll start with you since uh or
rather Mike, sorry, we'll start with you
since uh Matt started in the openings.
You will have five minutes for your
closing thoughts. Any final things you
want to share? and the time will start
when you begin speaking, sir.
Awesome. Hey, thank you for the
opportunity. Uh hopefully this was
helpful. I just want to just final
thoughts. I want everyone to understand
that it is really important when you're
studying law to understand the context
of the ancient neareastern covenantal
relationship between God and an entity.
It's very clear if you study the
covenants that the ten commandments
which is the topic for this evening if
kept in their context the ten
commandments are a part of the mosaic
covenant. That Mosaic covenant very
clearly is given to the Israelite
nation.
I don't know how many of you I'm not
Israelite. I'm not Jewish. I'm a
gentile. Um, so when you extract, first
of all, when you divide and cut apart
the law, I would argue that you're
you're not really keeping the law in its
context. You're making it apply to what
you want it to to work for you. All 613
were a part of the unit, the entire
covenantal relationship that was between
the Israelite nation exclusively and
Yahweh.
When we go to the new covenant which was
prophesied about in Jeremiah and I
believe Ezekiel, when we go to the new
covenant which is ratified in the blood
of Christ, it's very clear and I think
Matt and I would would agree on this
point. How do we how are we made right
with God? What is our responsibility in
that? Well, nothing except belief in his
faithfulness.
anytime you add and my challenge here is
is a little bit difficult with the
avenous terminology because yes there is
an expression of our love for God
absolutely but there has to be a clear
distinction between law or our
expression of the law and gospel
there you cannot unite the two if the
gospel is that Jesus Christ was faithful
he was the lambless lamb slain for us.
If we believe on that on him, then we
are saved. Nothing that we do from that
is a part of our salvation. Um so it's
very very clear that the new covenant
which is a covenantal relationship
between all humanity is a unilateral
covenant. It is all Jesus and his
faithfulness. It is not based on our own
works or as Matt mentioned, our
expression of how we're saved because
our sinful nature is always going to
express Paul talked about this. He
wrestled with the flesh. He wrestled
with things constantly. There's never
going to be a point at which we prior to
glorification ever truly express
our glorified bodies until that event.
So the new covenant is all Jesus. It's
not us. Our belief in what Jesus did and
his faithfulness is what saves us. Yes,
the the Bible does talk New Testament
does talk about Jesus talks about the
laws of Christ or the laws of Messiah
which is all about how we interact with
our neighbors, how we interact with each
other, how we image the body of Christ.
But none of that has any connection or
implications to our salvation. And I
know the common rebuttal to that is,
"Oh, you're just an antonyomian." No,
that's not what's going on. The law
plays an important role. The law is
supposed to point out sin. It's supposed
to show us our need of a savior. But the
law never saves us. It only condemns.
That's what Paul talked about. So
because of Christ's faithfulness, we now
do not have to be under the condemnation
of the law. Instead, we are under
Christ. We are unified with Christ. And
therefore,
we can rest assured that we are saved.
Does that mean we're going to be
perfect? No, it does not. Does that mean
we need to treat other people as
Christians and as images of Christ?
Absolutely. But it's always important to
separate the two. Your expression is not
what saves you. It isn't an indication
of your salvation. It isn't this. The
ten commandments are not the standard by
which you're saved. You are saved by
your faithfulness in Christ and only in
Christ's work on the cross.
All right. Thank you for that, Mike.
Matt, the same thing will now be
extended to you. You will have five
minutes, sir, for any of your closing
remarks.
All right. So, first off, thank you so
much, Miles, and everybody watching and
thank you, Mike, for this uh this lively
discussion. Um, I just want to reiterate
again, and I appreciate you using my
phrase that what what uh um our
expression of our faith is not what
saves us is exactly what I said in the
beginning. Um, I never said the law
saves us. And I want to make it
perfectly clear that the distinction
between the law of God as the ten
commandments versus the law of Moses as
the other I guess 613 or sorry 603 is a
distinction that Paul himself
emphatically makes in Ephesians chapter
2 where he literally talks about in
verse 15 that what was abolished in the
flesh of Christ was the enmity even the
law of commandments contained in
ordinances. the law of commandments
contained in ordinances which he refers
to again in Hebrews 9 as a carnal law.
So there is a distinction although in
the context of the Jewish economy when
they were in a sovereign nation it was
all under one because obviously they
were in a you know in a in a in a
theocracy. However, there was always a
distinction between the moral law of
God, the ten commandments as expressed
by him and written by his own finger
versus the other ones which were
abolished at the cross, which is
emphatically what it says. The new
covenant, by the way, is the law of God
written in our hearts, not written in
stone. Right? That's the new covenant
experience. That's what 2 Corinthians 3
is, is that the new covenant is
highlighting the glorious ministry of
Christ. that what Christ did is what
what we couldn't do because we were weak
sinful human beings and that what Christ
did is that he bridged that gap. He
obeyed in our behalf and when a believer
accepts Christ his obedience becomes any
obedience that we do is is really his
obedience. The focus is not on us. The
focus is always on him. It's always on
his righteousness and it's always on his
love for us. the summary that he brought
about the laws of Christ are love uh is
correct and in Romans 13 we he
reiterates that hey what is summarized
as that is the six commandments after
the fourth one 5 6 7 8 9 10 that those
commandments are summarized as love your
neighbor as yourself right these
principles God has always had they were
eternally from even you know even in the
time of garden of Eden um when we look
in the Bible we have to understand that
he or others would like to look at the
context of ancient neareastern uh you
know mindset and culture as opposed to
the context of the Bible like in Romans
7. There was a clear example where he'd
rather look at the context of culture
instead of the context of the scripture.
Right? Paul in Romans 7 was absolutely
clear that the law that he was referring
to was the ten commandment law. That law
is spiritual.
That law is good and just and holy. And
that law expresses God's love to us and
our reciprocating love to him. I asked
him earlier and I'll say this again. In
a faithful relationship, how that
relationship is expressed is in how we
treat that faithful covenant is how we
what we do with it. The way Abraham
expressed his faithfulness to the
covenant of the Lord was obviously in
letting in in in you know letting God
have his time with Sarah. the way he
didn't express his his faithfulness to
that is him choosing Hagar and that was
an expression of unbelief and all we're
saying and you look into Revelation and
all throughout what's not in the city of
God are uh all sorts of people who have
all sorts of uh you know rebellious
issues mongers and and
abominations and things like that liars
even right these are all expressions of
the ten commandments all I'm saying is
that our focus in our life is not geared
towards just hey am I obeying the ten
commandments or not. And and that's how
I live my life. It is not once you have
Christ in your heart, these things will
automatically be fulfilled out as long
as you let it happen. God's law is not
something that you can just check off.
It is something that's going to
constantly be expressed in your life.
Right? We have the laws written in our
hearts and it expressed by this
indwelling spirit when we accept him and
we accept uh his love and his grace and
his faith for us. That's how it's
expressed. It's all we're saying. We're
not saying you're saved by the law. Uh
but the law is definitely has an
important part uh because it identifies
that God is working in you to will and
to do of his good pleasure. Not ours,
not my work. It is not me that is
mustering up the strength to do it. It
is God that works in you. And every
believer in Christ, if you've truly
accepted Christ, you will see that yes,
there are now things that you are aware
of that you probably weren't aware of
that you were, you know, in a uh, you
know, sinning relationship with someone
or whatever the case is. And all of a
sudden, your conscience now is awakened
and now you're starting to feel the
spirit purge these things from your
life.